[Music]
hi everyone can hear me correct yeah
thanks for coming
let's play this horrible horrible title
what are we going to be talking about
today so you might be wondering why are
we talking about memory usage when
memories abound memories really quite
cheap especially given given the cloud
and how it scales and how its
progressively getting less expensive
CPUs are fast and and all that stuff but
fun fact you can get terabytes of memory
on a single machine on a table yes so it
might me it might be a non-issue but
there's a few things there's a few
reasons why I want to talk about this
topic one is whilst memory is cheap it's
not actually free it can be a bottleneck
especially in some performance-critical
software data locality matters meaning
that having a terabyte of data on s3 or
on a ZFS or on your local this is
something different than having it in
memory or any CPU cache well not a
terabyte of memory obviously so that
that matters quite a lot and last but
not least why should we waste space if
it's cheap and easy not to so let's
start by something doing something
fairly basic but something that's might
be a bit too low-level and it just we're
going to be using individual bits in our
bytes to store a boolean value so true
and false values which might sound like
not a great idea but it turns out it's
not that bad so to see how we can do
that let's imagine that well imagine
let's have a number in this case 109 and
let's look at the bit representation how
does it look like if we look at the at
the number as its sort in in a
memorandum computer so it's just a
collection of of ones and zeros and here
it leverages the fact that we can take
any positive integer and we can
decompose it as a sum of distinct sums
of two so that's the base two
representation so 109 is 2 to power of 0
plus 2 2 3 5 & 6 and that's what the the
ones in
the in the bite represent so the so the
zero is we don't have that power of two
whilst the the red one so the so the red
bits the ones are that we're actually
taking this power of two two to get our
get our number so this is how how the
value of hundred nine is represented and
you could scale that out to you know you
had 16-bit numbers 32-bit numbers 64-bit
numbers that's just varies by the number
of bits that you're using and you know
so defines how big of a range of a
numbers of members you can represent so
if we look at the number and the end by
and a bit representation of it we can we
can look at it two ways either we can
say okay so this is 109
that's a fine number that's that's one
piece of information or we can look at
it as a distinct pieces of information
so these are eight values true and false
that we can squish into this time
representation of a single byte so so
that means that we can take let's say a
megabyte of memory so that's a more or
less a million bytes and we can store
eight million bits of information in
that so a single megabyte of memory can
can let us know true false information
about eight million pieces of whom eight
pieces of pieces of data so that's why
it's used for example in in some
explanations implementations of data
frames or if you have a boolean series
that you actually want to store true and
false values in some column you can you
can serialize this in this in this very
condensed matter in these individual
bits so it's it's very efficient
especially for for random access is very
efficient in terms of how small it is so
it can fit into your memory if it's a
small enough it's it's very scalable
because you only need one bit of
information per per unit of data it's
trivially serializable because already
serialize because it just it just raw
raw bytes and it has various use cases I
just included a few so you can for
example just store a filter is also if
you filtering some data then you want to
store which rows match that filter so
you can store it in a in a you know in a
large bitmap just denoting one where the
row matched and 0 where it didn't and
then you can combine these individual
filters if you want to do some sort of a
combined filtering
and you can save these filter these
photo results locally because it's such
a it's such a small piece of data but
representing quite a large amount of
information so this is all well and good
but what is the catch or why why are we
not using bitmaps for everything so the
main so one of the main reasons is that
it's not very good for a sparse data bus
part and by sparse data I mean something
like it's very similar to the way that
we represent sparse matrices if you have
a matrix of thousand by thousand values
but only two of them are nonzero or
three of them are nonzero you're not
going to be saving one million
individual numbers just to represent of
all Balbus 200 by three as zeros because
that's just a waste of space and it's
also slow to access the non zero values
etc so that's the same with bitmap so
let's say you've got a bitmap that will
tell you filter results for a data frame
with a million rows and only two rows
are matching so you still need to
allocate a million bits so what is 820
kilobytes or something only to denote
that hey Rho 1 and Rho 990,000 512 is is
actually set so that's the that's the
main disadvantage of bitmaps there are
still crucial and they're still very
useful for for a smaller smaller piece
of data so if you know that you've got
let's say 16 or 24 or some smaller
number of values they need to safe for
example many times then they are still
useful but once you get into these
larger bitmaps where you've got a
sparsity of information then that's
where they show their weakness there is
a solution to that so that is a there's
a few compression algorithms it's not
like you take the the byte array and
just compressed using gzip or lz4 or
something like that there's compression
mechanism similar to what you would
define in columnar databases where you
just take oh here's a 1 that's repeated
a hundred times so instead of saving 100
once I'm gonna save the number 100 and
then that's going to denote here's a
here's a run of hundred ones and there's
a few few of these compression
mechanisms which basically allow you to
compress these these bitmaps and that's
why tools like loosing Tuesday the
searching technology behind solar in the
last surge or high spark
other software that we use in in the Big
Data sphere are using these compressed
big massive because if they represented
the true-false rays explicitly in in
bitmaps that would take a lot of space
that would be really expensive to send
over the network or or retrieve from
memory or disk so I'm not going to go
through the through the compression
mechanisms but there's a few one of the
most popular ones is fairly recent one
of roaring bitmaps so now that we have
now that we have bitmaps what can we
what can we do with them so the the rest
of the talk I'm gonna cover two to more
data structures that are quite useful in
in data engineering or data work in
general the first one is a bloom filter
so what a bloom filter does it's just to
preempted this is a probabilistic data
structure and that means that it doesn't
give you exact answers which might sound
odd that why would you save something
that you can't retrieve one for one but
it's gonna make sense in a minute
so the way so the way it works is that
it gives you two kinds of answers so you
I'm sorry so you treat it as a set so
it's a set of value so you've got a set
of values let's say you've got a caching
service and you want to cache cache a
million objects and you want to see
which objects you've cashed so you could
represent this as you know you would
save all the individual keys and some
sort of a tree structure and then you
look it up but then this data structure
grows linearly with the with the number
of keys that you that you've got saved
what bloom filters do that they allow
you to have a fixed piece of memory
where you can save set information and
then you can query it and get two kinds
of results is are they're gonna give you
a rights are they're gonna tell you yeah
this this this field is maybe in this in
this set or is going to tell you it's
definitely not in the set and also the
the to only answers that you can get and
you can tune how how accurate it's gonna
be and that's basically the the length
of a trip
so the way it works is that we hash so
we hash each value that we want to save
in this in this bloom filter and we
store it so that's the that's the short
and so let's let's look at a better
representation so here we've allocated
two bytes of memory so we've got 16 bits
here down here and we want to insert a
value so the first sketch is that we're
not normally going to be using one hash
function we're going to be using two in
reality we could be using six or seven
where we're gonna get to that so we've
got two hash functions hash one hash to
so we want to insert the value dog so
we're gonna hash dark and he's gonna
just imagine that it's modulo 16 it's
not really important we're gonna hash it
one's gonna get value of 3 there we go
that's as much interaction as you're
gonna get today we're gonna hash it
again we're gonna get the value of 15 so
we're gonna set these two bits then
we're gonna get a second value cat we're
gonna hash it once it's gonna give us
value 1 house [ __ ] again is gonna get a
give us 15 we've already got that set so
we don't have to do anything with that
and then it's query time we've got our
large data structure so let's see what
we've got in it so let's say somebody
else comes to this blue filter and asks
is rabbit in this set so they hash it
with a with the first hash function they
got a value of 4 and they can
immediately stop because as you can see
the but number 4 is not set so there's
no way that somebody could have input it
rabbit into this set because otherwise
that bid would have been set if they ask
if is horse in our set oh yeah I change
the size today just so that I could fit
it in one line and I forgot to change
that horse so let's imagine that's an
ant so we add a [ __ ] once we got a one
that's set we hash it again that's 12
that's not set so so we can abandon it
only after the second hash function and
the third example and that's the that's
the crucial one if we hash the value of
our ones get 15 hash it again get a 1 so
we went we would say yes I was possibly
in our set but as you can see it's a
false positive because we never
inserted this this value in our bloom
filter so that basically covers all the
all the all the other things that can
happen when you're inserting data into
the bloom filter and then querying them
back from it so you might be asking well
isn't this sort of false positive rate
kind of a bad thing well it kind of is
but you can you can mitigate it by just
allocating more than two bytes of memory
usually and and by having more more hash
functions you still need to be self
aware of how many unique values are
going to be inserting into that into
that bloom filter but once you've got
this set there's a few calculators
online where you can just input how many
distinct values you're expecting to
input what sort of false positive right
you wanna you wanna you want to have and
it's going to tell you Oh use six hacks
six independent hash functions and a
hundred megabytes of memory or something
like that so so so that's what that's
what happens in practice with a large
chunk of memory more hash functions and
just to give you an idea of where it's
used because it's such a small data
structure it's really really fast to
interrogate so you only need to hash a
value a few times
which a hash of a value you can do that
millions of millions of times per second
per core so so there's really cheap so
it's often used as a sort of a buffer
between your program and some sort of a
remote search you can think of it as
like a database as three or some some
other remote thing which you could take
milliseconds or even more to query so
you might have that buffer of the bloom
filter where you would ask is this have
we ever seen this thing do we have this
in our database and if you've got it
tuned well you can't you can return if
it says no then you know for sure that
it's that it's not in our database so
you don't have to worry about querying
it querying it but if it says yes then
you double check and then that's the
only way that's the only reason why you
would you would go there so that's the
that's the bloom filter in essence in in
in practice it also is very useful if
you've got a large sort of matrix of
data so for example medium uses it for
article recommendations so instead of
saving all of the articles per user so
the IDS of all the articles that each
user has read place
a balloon photraghper users which they
can interrogate instead of interrogating
the whole list of articles which which
just grows over time whereas the bloom
filter just stays stays constant so that
was the first probabilistic data
structure the second one and very I
would say aptly named but it's just
really named it's called hyper log-log
it's it's got more or less one use case
it's used for a distributed distinct
count distinct count and again it's
proximate it's a probability greater
structure and and it does exactly that
and nothing more well not really
anything else you might ask like why why
is it why is this useful but if you look
at for example presto from Facebook or
spark or redshift if you do come
distinct and look at the docs
it says yeah this is countless things it
gives you the exact number of distinct
values but then next to they they have
an approximate can which uses hyper log
log in the background and it gives you a
proximal distinct count whilst not using
using as much memory and it could make a
difference of hours in terms of query
run time you could and it also makes a
huge difference in terms of memory usage
which we're gonna touch because I'm
using I'm saying extremely low memory
it's it's kilobytes of memory to to
estimate cardinality carnelli use of
billions of values so you can so you
could be spending gigabytes or dozens of
gigabytes of memory to calculate the the
exact distinct count whereas with the
high Palala you could you could say
within the margin of to four percent
something like that i can tell you the
distinct count and use it use only a few
kilobytes of memory against
probabilistic so how does it work
so we hash each value we look at the
number of leading zeroes in that byte
representation we track the maximum of
these of the number of of zeros then
there's some magic that happens and then
we get the cardinality so what is that
magic
so the so the key observation that the
authors of the hyper log log or firmly
the log log algorithm hat was that if
you hash a value which returns a random
but deterministic hash value there's
there's a distinct property of the
number of of leading zeros in that hash
because he if we look at it this is this
is these are all the combinations of a
4-bit let's say we've got a 4-bit hash
function which is not very useful
because only gives you 16 16 different
values if we look at the leading leading
0 so we've got 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
we've got 8 values which don't have any
leading zeros than 4 which have 1 2
which have 2 etc so because it's a it's
a it's a it's a basic representation of
a random number it's going to have this
property of 2 to the power of K of
leading zeros and we can leverage that
let's look at another example so let's
say we're in certain in certain
different values into our into our hyper
long log so we're going to take a dog
we're going to hash it with our trivial
hash function I'm gonna have one leading
0 so we're gonna track that we've seen
one leading 0 cat that doesn't have any
so the maximum still one I was going to
increase that to two and we're going to
keep the two until the end because we
didn't get any more than two so by
leveraging the statistical property of
the of the number of leading zeroes in
in the hash function in the hash values
that we've seen we can estimate how many
distinct values we've we've seen in the
in the data so far there are two main
issues with this if we say oh we've seen
six leading zeros so I'm gonna say 2 to
the power six of distinct values that's
fine estimate very wrong usually but
fine
but then if you saw seven you know say
out you to the power 7 and you've got
this this gap you can only estimate 2 to
the power of K of distinct values of 64
128 then 256 it's
ever gonna be really that that accurate
also it's very susceptible to chance so
let's this is only a statistical
property of the leading of the number of
leading zeroes in those in those hash
values but what if by chance you get
thirty two leading zeros and then you
can say ah there's been four billion
distinct values and you've only seen two
so that could happen so the solution to
both of these problems is to use buckets
so if you look at the if we look at that
the hash value again so we saw the three
leading zeros down there we can look at
the other side well it doesn't really
matter what the implementation here it
differs sometimes you look at the same
side just shift it anyway it's we look
at the other side when you say oh here's
zero one zero so we're gonna we're going
to look at the other side of the of the
hash value to get us some sort of a
bucket so we're going to look at the the
leading zeros but we're going to assign
it to two different buckets so we're
going to say for all the hash values
that we've seen that had the bucket
identification of zero one zero we're
going to track a maximum for that one
then we're gonna attract a maximum for
four three zero etc so since we were
using three bits per bucket and we're
going to get eight eight different
buckets and then we can track these
Maxima per each bucket and then we can
average out the that is thing values
that we get for each bucket so we've got
any outliers even the I think the
original implementation had that you
just throw out the outliers because you
had so many buckets you could have like
2000 buckets are just gonna throw out
the the outliers the current one uses a
harmonic mean to sort of smooth out
these these extremes so so you get what
so you get what what we wanted so we
shot a short our data into these buckets
based on some other bits that's just a
different side different part of the of
the of the hash value you keep the you
do the same thing you keep the you keep
track of the of the number of leading
zeroes for each for each bucket the
average average I'm not a simple average
but a harmonic mean then there's a few
bias correction constants and then and
then that's it and the and the number of
charts or number of buckets determines
how accurate it's going to be
and the usual usually you would use like
mm about 2,000 buckets but since you're
only tracking the number of bits which
you can say which you can save in less
than a byte then we'd only take two
kilobytes to save this this is my for me
information and newer newer
implementations are actually just using
like six bits to to determine they to
track the maximum because that's that's
all you need but that's just
implementation detail so so what is it
then it's a it's an algorithm with a
tiny memory footprint it's got a tunable
error rate it can be updated so you can
just keep this this set of buckets this
these Maxima just keep it in memory and
just as data streams in you're just
gonna keep updating the maximum if
they're if they are ever ever changing
and then you can calculate a cardinality
at any point since that's so small you
can have like a distinct count per let's
say your article if you've got a if
you've got a if you've got a new site
and it's really easy to track how many
readers have have read it without
storing the individual IDs or anything
it can also be merged so you can have
and that's that's what brings the
distributed part into the into the
algorithm so you can merge these these
estimates from from multiple from
multiple threads or even computers so
that's why that's why the technologies
like presto spark are using it I just
shard the data and then calculate the
distributed the count per each per each
chart and then they just merge them
together and the merge is actually quite
simple because you're just gonna align
the buckets and just take the Maxima
from each pair obviously need the same
the same length and same hash functions
but since it's the same implementation
you would you would get that there's a
few extensions I'm not gonna go over
them the one log log classes is mostly
about improving the the accuracy and
lowering the the memory used like it's
too high or anything and B and then
there's there's a few other things where
I think high Berman has allows for
intersections etc so there's been some
research but but the base the base
algorithm is
is the case old just like bloom filter
here's a slide that I've added today so
there's not much on it because I
realized I don't have a good summary so
what is it for it really does depend on
what area in what sort of position
you're in and so it could range from oh
this is cool I'm gonna implement it just
because I think the the concepts are
interesting and I recommend implementing
all three because they're they're quite
interesting it's sort of in a sort of
increasing increasing complexity but
bitmaps are really really interesting by
how easy they are in to implement bloom
filters a bit bit trickier but it's so
just bit fiddling just modular and stuff
like that hi Paula is a bit more
involved because you've got all the
sharding and the bias question etc but
they're it's a really good learning
experience so that's one thing the other
thing is that since they are used in in
quite a lot of software that we use for
for distributed computing or not not
just this really come being even like
single computing it's by good to know
what sort of properties they have so
when you when you're using them like the
thing like the a parks distinct when
you're running it like why is it so
efficient why is it so fast wise it's
why is it not crashing with out of
memory whereas the source of the error
is its sampling or is it doing something
else so I I have the mindset that I'd
like to understand things that sound
sound strange so hyper log log sounded
strange so I wanted to know why it why
it works and you might even use it as a
data structure yourself so we we've used
hi blogger a few times just to just to
save these distinct values and just
update or update them over time so so
that's that there's many reasons why you
might be interested in my there's many
reasons why you might not be and that's
it so there's a few there's a few other
resources that I that I found quite
useful there's a really good video from
CPB Khan which is epub c++ conference
but as not a lot of C++ in that video
and it just got a great overview of
these algorithms and many more the
there's a whole family of probabilistic
data structures that I would recommend
you to explore because it's not just
about about sets in bloom filters and
distinct values in in in hyper Loblaws
but there's also things like hi
permanence cache which which allows you
to get a bit more information for each
each value that you're inserting and and
a few other few other algorithms which
give you approximate answers at very low
memory cost and and yeah that's it
[Applause]